we're counting down to tomorrow's
historic SpaceX launch with our launch
America coverage two NASA astronauts are
set to blast off from US soil for the
first time since the space shuttle
program ended back in 2011 this is a
look at the space X Falcon 9 rocket that
will send those astronauts to the
International Space Station it is
standing on the very same launch pad
that launched the Apollo 11 mission to
the moon
mark Strassmann is at the Kennedy Space
Center with how SpaceX got to the brink
of making space history mark good
morning morning Tony you know a million
little things have to go right for any
successful launch but a big one is the
weather after a couple of dreary days as
you can see skies are improving
conditions are now 60% favorable for a
launch tomorrow afternoon so let's take
a look now at SpaceX a company with a
history of beating long odds they wrote
in Tesla's to the launch pad in a final
rehearsal but for astronauts Bob Behnken
and Doug Hurley this is their ride that
matters the crew Dragon capsule now
poised to blaze a new American path to
space six years ago Elon Musk's company
only had a model of the space ship but
NASA awarded SpaceX a 2.6 billion dollar
contract to fly its astronauts to the
International Space Station liftoff of
the SpaceX Falcon 9 rocket by then
SpaceX had already made history the
first company to fly cargo their station
on to capture complete and the first to
develop reusable rockets slashing costs
and revolutionising the business model
of space by 2018 development of crew
dragon was well underway at SpaceX
headquarters in Hawthorne California we
met the astronauts training to be its
first crew coming out here it's a real
motivator this workforce is so young
they're excited about what they do
they're passionate about what they do
and it kind of reinvigorates you about
why you got into the business you know
how many years ago for Apollo 11 the
average age of a flight controller was
26 there was precedent for this
obviously we weren't there but I would
certainly say that the NASA of the 60s
was not drastically I'm like SpaceX of
now learning as they go learning about
flying in space learning the hard
lessons and being successful start and
liftoff hard lessons like this one in
2015 a Falcon 9 rocket lifting cargo to
the space station disintegrated minutes
after liftoff and we peer to have had a
launch vehicle failure and last year
another setback when a crew Dragon
capsule exploded during a ground test
while it's disappointing it also can be
a real gift to the final design the
company embraced its failures and we
totally Frank if there hasn't been some
hardware that blowed up we grew up on a
test and I don't think you tested it
hard enough that's the reality I think
sometimes the aerospace industry shai's
away from failure in the development
phase when shot well as SpaceX is
president Musk's right hand it looks bad
politically it's tough and and the media
certainly makes a lot out of failures
but candidly that's the best way to
learn is to push your systems to their
limit learn where you're weak and make
things better with us SpaceX is now on a
streak of 62 successful launches and
crew Dragon is armed with an escape
system initiated if the rocket falters
its engines can push away the capsule
landing the crew safely in the ocean and
we have swept this down you genuinely
believe if something goes wrong you've
got options absolutely yeah we really do
focus on trying to remind folks that you
know there are people on the pointy end
of this rocket ship and that's important
to us there's another aspect of it that
we are kind of an extension of what
they're trying to accomplish that's
really their goal is to safely fly
humans and so I think we've kind of
bring that home as we kind of walk
through the plant tomorrow as launch
shapes up as SpaceX is most pivotal test
yet succeed and America's back in the
human space launching business fail and
this country's dream of launching its
own astronauts into space again will be
set back in
definitely my heart is sitting right
here and I think it's going to stay
there until we get Bob and Doug safely
back from the International Space
Station
when SpaceX was founded in 2002 Elon
Musk Handicap gist chances of succeeding
at 1 in 10 18 years later its rocket is
on the pad and his crew is set to make
history Tony yeah mark hard not to be
nervous for them but also extremely
excited only countries have done this in
the past now a company is trying to do
it but really it's all of humanity
trying to do it when you look up at the
night sky you realize we have gone
almost barely not at all into it and it
goes on forever all right mark thank you
very much